Just happened everyone agrees the footage is phenomenal. It was amazing technological wizardry
Everyone loves it, but there's something that is missing when you view it over the internet everyone
that's ever been to an actual space launch will tell you it's the sound of the event that just
Overwhelms your body and that's kind of lost when you're looking through a screen, right?
So it's time for me to introduce you to my other youtube channel. It's called the sound traveler
I used binaural 3d audio if you will to transport your body to the location it kind of tricks your mind
It's a acoustic type mental thing going on just trust me it works.
Here's how it works get your headphones put your headphones on it only works
if you have headphones
Make sure the left headphone is on your left ear make sure the right headphone isn't your right ear there once you get set up
your
Calibrated the Vehicle Assembly Building is the largest single story building
In the world this is where they assemble the Rockets you are one of only 20 photographers credentialed
That's allowed onto the top of the Vehicle Assembly Building with your headphones on we're gonna walk through the Vehicle Assembly Building with these photographers
Get on some elevators do some catwalk stuff so that your mind gets calibrated to that 3d audio
Then walk out to the cameras and get ready for launch there's three things
I want you to listen for number one at the countdown listen to all the shutters firing from the cameras around you you can hear
Where they are number two once the rocket lifts off the pad you can no longer hear the cameras. It's so loud
What kind of aircraft is overhead and where it is relative to your mind? Okay, Go enjoy launch and then we'll get ready for re-entry
thank you
Thank you
there it goes
lift off
Lots of noise
That sound adds so much for me. That is so incredible
Okay, the next part that I absolutely love so the Rockets up up in a way right the two boosters
Safely separate they do a little pirouette and they come back without touching each other and they come back in
With a re-entry burn the part that I love I mean as an engineer this just tickles all the right parts of my brain
the fact that the video feed from both of those boosters
Looks like it's just one booster played on two different screens
I love that that means the guidance and control algorithm was so finely tuned
But they just nailed it so tip of the hat to the guidance control team that did that
Very very impressed the next thing that you missed by not being there because we're watching it on a screen
And we're hearing the cheering at Hawthorne or the sonic booms as it approaches the pad
So here's how this works according to SpaceX there are three sonic booms per booster
And they're caused by in order number one the engine down there causes the first sonic boom where the legs connect to the booster
That's the second one and the third one's caused by the grid fins up on top of the booster now
There's three sonic booms per booster
We have two boosters that six sonic booms right, now
Experience this in 3d with your headphones still see if you can count how many sonic booms you hear
And this is what a person hears when they're down at the Cape when this goes down check it out
got them
woooow
sonic boom's?
6 sonic booms
holy, holy mackerel
I didn't count six I counted ten pump. It dump. It dump. It dump it down I
Went back and looked at the waveform the reason you see ten. There's supposed to be three per booster
There's three with echoes and so the waveform overlays in such a way that it sounds like five. It's fascinating anyway
That is a sound traveller video. I hope you enjoyed this episode of the sound traveler
I'm promoting it here on smarter every day in hopes that people will go and subscribe to that when I feature a
guest sound traveler I write up this little contract here and
I make sure to pay them and I also make sure to promote them and this particular sound traveler was trevor maehlman trevor
Helps me with all the eclipse stuff that we've done in the past but
According to our contract that we wrote. I am now supposed to promote Trevor's MySpace page
so if you want to support Trevor Mullin
professional rocket photographer you can I'm just kidding he has a patreon trevor is trying to figure out how to make a career out of
professional rocket photography
And if you know anything about how intellectual property works it is really really hard to do that everybody wants to offer you promotion
When you just need money to eat, so I payed Trevor for this endeavor
and
I also want to set him up for the long haul and the way to do that is patreon so if you want to support
Trevor you'll notice all the other photographers were more established in their careers Trevor's not so if you want to support a young man
That's doing awesome things and on top of that. He gives you incredible photographs in exchange for your financial support
I'll leave a link down below. So if you want to pack up your photography gear now with Trevor
I'll let you do that and I'll leave a link on the screen to subscribe to the sound traveler one humble request
To subscribe to that channel because it's a pet project. I love anyway. I'm Destin you're getting smarter every day. Have a good one
Holy cow
Wow
Now I'm the first person to see this footage, but I cannot wait for all of you see this this is
This is gonna be crazy. This is really gonna be awesome